what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and marvel studios is
going to be attending san diego
comic-con this year and they're also
going to have a very large presence at
d23 and we're expecting some pretty big
reveals about the mcu at both of these
events plus not to mention disney plus
day is also coming up where we hope to
learn a little bit about marvel's disney
plus shows that they have upcoming
rumors have been going around that
they're going to be some pretty big
reveals and recently to top it all off
kevin feige the president of marvel
studios has come out and said that we
are about to learn soon how everything
is going to tie together and which
direction the mcu is going so hopefully
that means we're going to get a glimpse
of all of this at sdcc and at d23 the
only question is what exactly is going
to be announced at these events well
there is a very very long list of all of
the movies and shows that are confirmed
which we'll briefly talk about but
what's most exciting is the movies and
the shows that have been rumored to be
in development over at marvel studios so
that's what we'll focus on today the
possible projects that marvel studios
could be announcing at these major
events that are happening within a few
months and if you're new to the channel
and you love marvel be sure to subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest news now between all of the
movies and disney plus shows that are
confirmed whether that's directly by
marvel studios or a major trade outlet
like variety or the hollywood reporter
and all of the movies and shows that are
rumored there are over 50 different
projects that we have to talk about that
are up and coming after all kevin feige
did say that whatever they announced
which is usually five to six years into
the future they actually have five plus
years more than that planned out so at
any given point in time marvel studios
has 10 plus years planned and if you
think about it marvel studios is doing
three to four movies a year and they're
doing about four to five disney plus
shows a year right now as well if we do
a low number and say that marvel studios
is going to release seven projects a
year that means in the next five years
there's going to be 35 different mcu
projects that come out and again that's
a low number and marvel studios has 10
years planned out right now which is
very very exciting so let's dive into
everything that's confirmed already
we'll quickly go through this and then
we'll get into the rumored ones
hopefully some that are going to be
announced at san diego comic con or d23
now i think most people know this
confirmed list but in case there's a few
on here that you don't know let's go
through all of them
of course the next one is going to be
thor love and thunder that comes out in
less than two weeks now then we have
black panther wakanda forever ant-man
and the wasp quantomania guardians of
the galaxy vol 3 the marvels fantastic
four blade deadpool 3 captain america 4
which is confirmed shanxi 2 which is
also confirmed a thunderbolts project
and spider-man homecoming 4 which kevin
feige and amy pasquale did confirm is in
the works now those are the confirmed
movies let's talk about the confirmed
disney plush shows and it starts with
miss marvel obviously that is out right
now she hulk attorney at law i am groot
secret invasion the echo series loki
season 2 what if season 2 iron heart
armor wars a wakanda series that is
untitled right now agatha house of
harkness spider-man freshman year which
is going to be an animated series marvel
zombies which is also going to be
animated a daredevil series and a wonder
man series that's a lot of upcoming
projects that are confirmed did you know
all of those or were there a few in
there that you forgot about or maybe
didn't know that's 27 mcu projects that
are confirmed to be coming but now let's
talk about the secret projects that
marvel studios could be working on in
the background that are rumored to be
coming within the next few years or so
for movies let's start off with nova and
this could be on the confirmed list it's
been reported by some trade companies
that the movie is coming and kevin feige
has said over the years that they
eventually are going to do a nova
project so even though this one is
technically confirmed marvel hasn't
really said anything about this so it's
going to be on the rumored for now but
then we have an atom warlock movie that
is rumored now we know adam warlock is
going to be introduced in guardians of
the galaxy vol 3. so a movie that is
about adam warlock would make sense that
would come after guardians 3. next
rumored project is an a-force movie
which is essentially a female avengers
team and based off of the direction that
disney and marvel studios is going i
would definitely say that this is a big
possibility now the next one is the
young avengers now marvel studios is
definitely setting up a young avengers
project the only question is is it going
to be a movie or a show we're unsure
about that right now then we have an
america chavez movie and a lot of people
really liked her in doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness so i wouldn't
be surprised if this was true and of
course a big one avengers 5. now we
haven't really heard much about a new
avengers movie yet from anyone at marvel
and there kind of isn't an avengers team
right now but hopefully marvel can shed
some light on this at one of these
events now the next one's kind of
interesting a big hero 6 film and yes
marvel does have the rights to do this
and i actually think a live action big
hero 6 movie would be pretty dang cool
but i don't know let me know what you
think about it we then have a black
knight movie which is pretty much
confirmed kit harington played dane
whitman in the eternals and in the
post-credits scene they set him up to be
the black knight so a black knight
project is definitely coming but nothing
has been announced yet now the next one
is a black panther 3 movie which i'm
sure they're going to do a black widow 2
movie which i'm not so sure they're
going to do but it has been confirmed
that scarlett johansson is coming back
to marvel but she'll be directing a
project perhaps it could be a black
widow project that is not focused on her
black widow however it could be focused
on yelena which i think a lot of people
would really enjoy then we have a blade
2 which is already rumored a captain
carter film which i think a lot of
people would like especially after
multiverse of madness captain marvel 3
which i'm sure will happen dr strange 3
which i'm sure will happen and eternals
2 which is basically confirmed but not
officially we then have an excalibur or
captain britain project and marvel has
kind of dropped some easter eggs already
for captain britain so i'm hoping this
one ends up being true and it looks like
it kind of is going to be true then
rumors have already started circulating
for a second fantastic four movie which
i'm pretty sure is confirmed but
obviously we have to get the first one
before the second one comes out then we
have a guardians of the galaxy vol 4 in
which a lot of the original guardians
team is not going to be a part of the
guardians of the galaxy moving forward
so i'm curious to see who the new team
would be then a hercules movie is being
rumored right now and this one has some
pretty good ground especially since thor
love and thunder is introducing greek
gods and plus moon knight introduced
egyptian gods it would make sense that a
hercules film would be in development
then we have an illuminati film that is
rumored and i personally hope that this
is true because we need a main mcu earth
616 illuminati but we need it done right
we need the x-men a part of it we need
the fantastic four part of it we need
the inhumans an avenger this could be
one of the greatest teams ever seen on
film a team that doesn't actually get
their butts kicked by the scarlet witch
now here we have some movies that marvel
studios is going to be doing with sony
an untitled black cat movie an untitled
miles morales movie which i'm sure just
has to happen at some point in time they
can't not introduce miles morales so
this is definitely coming especially
after no way home where jamie foxx's
electro said there's got to be a black
spider-man out there somewhere marvel is
definitely working on miles morales
right now then we have an entitled
spider-gwen movie which i really hope is
true because she is one of my favorites
and i would love to see a live-action
spider-gwen then we have a name war
movie which i'm sure is coming neymar is
going to be introduced in wakanda
forever and i'm sure it's only a matter
of time until he gets his own film plus
not to mention he should be a part of
the illuminati because he is in the
comics then we have a rumored thor 5
film in which chris hemsworth just said
that he'll play thor until marvel
studios essentially makes him stop so
this is likely we then have a century
movie and this has been rumored for
actually some time now i'm hoping it's
true a scarlet witch solo movie which is
pretty much confirmed marvel is trying
to keep it a secret but a lot of the
insiders have said yes they have heard
that it is in development right now or
at least is confirmed to be happening
soon we then have an entitled spider
woman film that olivia wilde is going to
be directing and this of course will be
with sony and then two big ones a world
war hulk movie which has been heavily
rumored recently and of course an x-men
film now the x-men film is kind of
confirmed kevin feige mentioned mutants
and x-men at san diego comic-con in 2019
but we don't know if they're going to be
introduced in their own movie in other
movies in a disney plush show we have no
idea at this point in time right now
which is why it's rumored because we
don't know if it's going to be an actual
movie at least not at first eventually
marvel will of course do an x-men film
but who knows how they'll start if you
have any good guesses let me know in the
comments down below and that's all of
the movies now let's talk about the
rumored disney plush shows agents of
atlas this one has been rumored for a
while and is most likely true the next
one though captain america the last
mission might not be so true especially
if you consider what chris evans has
said in some recent interviews for a
light year it doesn't really sound like
he's coming back unless they are talking
about sam wilson's captain america but
they're already doing captain america 4
with sam wilson so i doubt the series is
true but a captain carter series could
happen it's not confirmed if it's going
to be a movie or show but a disney plus
show would make a lot of sense then we
have a damage control in which the dodc
seems to be a kind of prominent group in
phase four so far so this one has a high
probability of happening then we have an
interesting and pretty cool one
daughters of the dragon with colleen
wing and misty knight i think this would
be a pretty cool show especially if they
did it kind of like a detective show i
would really watch this then there's a
rumored doctor strange show which i
don't think is going to happen i think
they're going to stick with movies for
doctor strange but then we have a ghost
disney plus show in which if we're going
to introduce him give him an actual
origin story in the mcu a disney plush
show might actually work for him we then
have a rumored heroes for hire disney
plush show which i think a lot of fans
would really enjoy and want to see
happen then we have a rumored howard the
duck show and we've actually seen him
pop up in the mcu he was also in what if
so this might actually be happening then
we have a very interesting one a journey
into the mystery disney plusha which i
would personally really like to see it
originally started out as kind of a
horror comic but then it changed to more
monster and science fiction and if it's
going to be on disney plus it won't be
scary but i definitely think that it
would be a really fun series we have a
rumored magipore series which would just
simply make sense it could focus on
sharon carter then a midnight suns
series which i would love to see but i
think i might like a movie a little bit
more so i hope it's a movie and not a
disney plush show the next rumored one
is pretty interesting a next wave disney
plush show now next wave for marvel was
satire it was extreme comedy this often
showed characters like captain america
acting kind of not so good but kind of
doing inappropriate jokes and things
like that like i said at satire and
comedy and i think would be pretty funny
then we have a rumored rescue series and
rogue series two separate ones not
together but i'm not sure about these
because one the x-men aren't introduced
yet so i don't know about a rogue series
and rescue well i'm not sure gwyneth
paltrow will do a rescue series but you
never know it would be cool to see what
tony stark's family is doing after his
death then there's a tallow series which
is the city from changchi there's
obviously a lot of history with talo and
that mystical city i think it would be
really cool to explore that then of
course we have an untitled 10 ring
series which is going to be about
xailing and they set this up at the end
of xiangchi in the post credit and then
there's also a win woo disney plus show
that is rumored to be happening which i
think would be really really cool we
could see all that he did with the 10
rings including how he might have found
them because we all want to know that
and like i mentioned there could be a
young avengers disney plush show but
we're unsure if it's a movie or a show
and that's it that's all of the rumored
shows that marvel studios could be
working on right now now these all come
from some type of an insider so they all
kind of have merit but of course at the
same time a lot of these might not
happen but at the same time a lot could
happen so what are you most excited for
on this rumored list what do you hope
marvel studios announces soon let me
know in the comments down below don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you can stay up to date on all things
happening in the mcu for live updates
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof